is going straight over towards the seat
front straight toward the seafront heavy
pedestrian traffic we're trying to give
him some space on both DeCamp we've got
a fail to stop uh skegness just going
back onto the sea Lane stand off
Direction left left generation towards
Butlins
we're just going back
go ahead
uh I see one male driver
um Skinner boarding it's a hard right
right right right Roman Bank
on the old Raymond Bank uh stand bath
Direction
traffic is high it's a right right into
a car park
it's going to be a deacon standby
Ty's got there
yeah foot offside tires
so vehicle back to the crossroads is
going straight over towards the seat
front straight over the seafront heavy
pedestrian traffic we're trying to give
him some space on birthday camp
foreign
[Music]
I don't know